how many Pilots have you helped writer
sell right now I am at 105
106 is in action and I also just heard
about another one that would make it 107
wow these are TV Pilots that for
streaming or also Network both both okay
great both and so writers are aware like
when you sell a pilot it doesn't mean it
goes to series it means you're selling a
pilot so I've had I think seven shows
now go to Series where they get picked
up and they're on the air so that is a
ratio that's very important for writers
to be aware of you can sell a pilot but
so many Pilots are bought per season and
the percentage that get to series that
get picked up is a much smaller number
and when I open my business my whole
focal point as a consultant was the
recognition that the TV pilot is
everything uh in taking a non-working
writer into being a working writer or in
an unrepresented writer to a represented
writer so my whole focus when I started
my business was how do I
demystify the pilot writing process so
writers know how to write a script that
will sell because having that
recognition is what will lead to an
outcome because scripts need to hit it
out of the ballpark in order
for something to sell in order for a
writer to
staff what are a few things that uh new
writers get wrong about selling a pilot
in addition to they'll be bought but not
necessarily be made which is news to me
I would say some of the things they do
wrong is the strategy of the Season Arc
so the season Arc and the central
conflict for the car
in that they are torn in two different
directions is everything to the
longevity of the show and I think the
mistake that writers make is they're so
focused on the pilot episode without the
recognition of are they building a big
enough well to where we can see one
season or several seasons of Story
coming from the
concept so is it just that they don't
have room for uh dilemma or is it just
too small of an idea what would stop
someone from having something that had a
big enough Arc I think the well what
stops someone from having a big enough
Arc has to do with also moving the
mindset of a feature writer beginning
middle end to a TV writer which is you
are
bookending your pilot with uh with a
strategy that is setting up season one
so you you have your series Arc that is
book ending and setting up season one
then if the strategy of the pilot Arc is
done correctly the pilot Arc is one step
toward the season one question so by the
end of the pilot we should have a very
clear sense of what is the internal and
the external question that is driving
season one and that's how you build a a
season Arc for example an old show that
more people know I the split that I
watched recently has probably one of the
best season art setups of any show I've
seen because it creates three seasons
based on the setup of the father who was
gone for 30 years the eldest daughter
who has a secret that could cost her her
marriage and the The Well of story
that's coming from a family law practice
that has to do with with family law and
domestic disruption so those three
components bring in the idea of story
and those three components built three
seasons of story and then a show like
Homeland the older show that I was
mentioning you look at the Brilliance of
the season one setup with the idea of is
Brody the prisoner of war the turn or
isn't he and every episode is yes no yes
no toward the season one question how
does a writer get in the room with the
right people to pitch a television
show there lies the mystery of so much
the writer should first focus on the
writing so many writers will get focused
on how do I get in a room and and the
thing is if the writing is where it
needs to be and hits it out of the
ballpark you will get into the
room and a way I've seen every writer
has a different Journey for how that
happens you can have writers who enter
all the competitions and enter some of
the more well-known competitions and hit
at the finalist or semifinalist or above
and you and they'll start to get
recognition within the community because
of how they're performing in
competitions you I've seen writers I
always with my writers tell
them if you hit semi finals or above in
a competition let me know and I will
give you a shout out on all of my social
social media because I have a lot of
Executives agents managers on my social
media so my feeling is if I see someone
who's getting Great accomplishments in
the competition World it means that
something is working so that's one
channel then you have the channel of the
writing programs that are at the studio
and networks that are these diversity
programs or just writing fellowships
where the intention of the program is to
identify out of sometimes two to 3,000
submissions what are the top eight
writers that are at a level that they
could be a working writer and then to
help facilitate that outcome then you
also have the channel of just the pure
strength of the
writing
that
you do the work to get it in the right
hands and that could involve working as
a writer's assistant and absorbing and
being a sponge and utilizing your
relationships when you know your script
is in a strong enough place to get you
to an outcome so it all comes down to
the script it all comes down to
knowing that you don't want to get into
a room until your script is at a level
that could
sell also knowing that whatever happens
in that room if you land in the room too
early and you're not ready there's
something to learn from that as well
does that happen a lot oh yes oh yes I
mean you have development Executives
that are you know listening to so many
pitches a day that you
can I always I you know writers have to
recognize that you can go into a room
and feel like
you don't have an audience because you
have a blank look on the development EX
face which happens a lot purposely
because they don't want to give you a
sense of what what's going on inside or
you can have someone who has a bazillion
fires that they're putting out that
they're attention isn't quite there and
I always tell writers you have the power
to read a room and know when you need to
grab their attention and know when you
are losing their attention how to bring
it back so never feel like when you're
losing the room that there is no way to
bring it back because you can bring it
back and always in your mind with your
pitch have an idea of all right a a
common place that you lose a room when
you're pitching is in the character
description
and if you don't give the log line and
you're giving this rambling view of the
characters and the the people hearing
your pitch are trying to think of the
framework of who is significant in what
way and why you're losing them so then
you can help save yourself by if you
recognize you never gave the log line
give the log line that that help helps
like brings it back on on track so and
there's value in all of it like the
failure in pitching brings knowledge and
every working writer has a string of
failures behind them that gets them to
where they need to be does this writer
have to live in the greater LA
area it used to be yes it used to be
with without a doubt in television you
had to live in LA it since the
pandemic it has broadened into you have
writers living all over the world
and the value is you can get writers who
are in different places and are at a
very high level of talent by not having
them have to be in Los Angeles so I have
seen writers live in other places at
this point in the entertainment industry
and succeed but the rule of thumb for
television is you should be in Los
Angeles unless if for example if you are
a known feature writer that could change
everything if you are a known feature
writer working in different places and
you are making the transition into
television or streaming and are people
are aware of your films then that can
change everything to I I know a
gentleman who did a thesis who his film
became huge and all of the um festivals
his film became huge and he never had to
start at the bottom of Television
because his films did his film did as
well as it did in the festival circuit
it had clout in television and he
literally like you know started with
selling a pilot and started at the top
and never moved to
LA but that's a rarity that's a rarity
that is a rarity you have in La the
value of being in La is that you are
soaking in the business you are around
people who share your passion you around
the work and when you're around the work
then you are in an a situation where you
can create
opportunity through getting your work
out out there so there there is a
tremendous value in living here for
writers that live other places I often
advise don't make the move until you
have three to four very strong scripts
in your portfolio then you are making
the move with a
strategy that could serve you and get
you to your goal quicker do you think
stories like the one you just told about
this gentleman who wrote a feature film
that did so well or others we've heard
you know there's there's countless names
where you know million dollar right off
the bat it it inspires writers or it
actually hinders them because they think
I'll be the next one and it actually
could stop them from getting a project
made because they think it's so they can
just jump cut I think it does both I
agree I think that when you have these
huge success stories just like when you
hear it was an overnight success and you
don't count the 10 years that went into
that overnight success and and Writer's
perception of the million dooll deal
happening uh to what feels like a newer
writer without having any sense of all
the work that went into it before that
outcome happened so
I I think the success of others I
writing is like yoga you have to not
compare your journey to anyone else but
your own and the idea of you have to
continuously be doing the work to be the
best writer that you can be and somebody
else having success or getting further
than you should not be something that
should
[Music]
that you see that the dream happens
every day in the entertainment business
it happens every day so anyone that gets
stuck in the victim role of of it's not
going to happen for me that is going to
mean that it chances are it won't happen
to you because you have to
believe in your talent and your gift in
order order for the outcome to happen
and people who are getting these million
dooll deals are people who are doing the
emotional work in that belief as well as
the work on the script and that overall
belief is getting them to that outcome
and then there's also the flip side of
sort of this aggressive like they can't
surpass me I mean some people are just
hardwired differently some people are
okay with other people being you know
ahead of them so to speak on the on the
social strata and some people they
cannot handle any type of rivalry like
that and I think that fuels certain
people too and it might actually work
for them I agree and I always
fear as a as a former executive I always
fear the
idea
of the envy and the jealousy of the more
higher level writers
being frightened of lower level writers
that are
showing True Value and that's why I
think it's so important that all Writers
Do the emotional work and you can have a
lower level writer and I've seen this
happen that has a tremendous voice that
threatens the upper level writers so
they won't get the positive feedback
that they need to get to that higher
level or they
will uh feel stunted at a time when they
should be
celebrated so that comes down to know
your voice know your gift
believe and don't get affected by what
others say or think follow your own
trajectory